hi i'm adam scott i'm here with buzzfeed
and i'm doing thirst tweets
the fact that adam scott hasn't done
thirst tweets when he's the hottest
person alive is a crime i mean i'm no
i'm no lawyer but let me check this real
quick i've got another device here
law.com
it is not a crime should it be i don't
think so but call your member of
congress name your kink ben wyatt
playing cones of dunshire yeah
yeah i think i'm there for that i think
cones of dunshire if nothing else is an
incredibly sexy game i think everyone
agrees on that adam scott enter my house
and cook me a calzone on my back
jesus is your back hot enough to cook
food on adam scott really does smile
like he's gonna [ __ ] someone's
girlfriend
what that description is interesting and
it's real just had a lengthy dream in
which i befriended adam scott i coerced
him into singing the acapella version of
sweet child of mine sounds like a fun
dream i wish i could sing like derek
does in stepbrothers but i uh for the
life of me i i simply can't however i am
the only one in that car who is uh
lip-syncing everyone else is singing
live honestly mr adam scott can get it
left right and center hashtag zaddy i
don't know what zaddy is a hotter daddy
oh okay there's nothing that will make
you feel less hot than your teenagers
looking at you like you're a giant
[ __ ] for saying hello i was most
attracted to adam scott and party down
because my type is guys with depression
i get it you would have loved me in the
late 90s ultimate sexual fantasy adam
scott making out with another adam scott
while i eat popcorn
in the corner ultimate ultimate sexual
fantasy i would just gross myself out
did i spend my day thinking about adam
scott on boy meets world yes was it a
good use of my time yes will i be taking
questions no when i did boy meets world
in
1995 or whatever did i think people
would be talking to me about it in 2022
no i did not adam scott could gut me
like a fish and i'd say thank you
really my only question on first dates
is going to be if they are consistently
on ed's side on big little lies and if
they're not it's over plain and simple
ed appreciates it and i say that because
all of my characters live on inside of
me and he just told me he appreciates it
is it too much to ask adam scott to
rearrange my guts uh no but you have to
ask in person adam scott could literally
run me over with a giant mechanic ball
sack and i'd still want to marry him
listen no empty threats allowed if you
have a giant mechanic ball sack and you
really really want to get married don't
tempt me adam scott could spit on my
grave and call me a and i would still
fancy him oh that started one way and
then it ended very sophisticated and
friendly i appreciate it i get it i
think adam scott should [ __ ] me inside
out and that's all i have to say well
alright i'm glad adam scott i'm so
thirsty for you i want you to come down
my throat snap my neck and hide my body
uh
thanks but no adam scott could get this
bussy any day what is this bussy oh
okay adam scott could get this bussy any
day does that mean even mondays because
you're saying any day and i feel like
mondays are usually like just busy
wall-to-wall stuff to do if you really
mean any day that's quite a commitment
thank you this was great thank you so
much everybody for for sending these
thirst tweets in thank you buzzfeed for
having me severance is on apple tv plus
uh new episodes come out on fridays
thank you wish i could sing yeah that
was also lip syncing